this video is sponsored by Squarespace
[Music]
come sit with me there's much to discuss
dude Too Close back up a bit you might
be forgiven for dismissing the side
plank as one of those exercises you get
in toning videos people just want to do
a bit of gentle exercise without really
going the extra mile but that's not
right so stop it the side plan because
it happens is a fantastic exercise that
can benefit anyone it can restore
functional healthy movements to anyone
with a whole host of issues and it's a
tool used by athletic coaches to help
their athletes produce more power and
explosiveness the side blank is an
exercise that can address hip issues
knee problems it can improve your gaits
your walking mechanics and it's
particularly good for your back and for
a whole host of back related issues in
fact a version of the plank is one of
the big three exercises recommended by
the back mechanic Dr Stuart McGill as
with all these things the key with the
side plank is to make sure you're doing
it correctly to make sure that you're
using it in the right context and to
adapt it to suit you whether that means
making it harder or easier okay so this
is one of the simpler movements to
explain and so I'm going to start by
just talking you through it basically
you're gonna lie down on your side
Place one hand directly underneath your
shoulder and then straighten out your
body what's important is there's a
straight line all the way down and that
you're not sagging at the waist or over
extending
I want to keep it nice and straight like
so and of course if you find that a
little bit difficult
you can put your elbow in the muddy
floor
like so
and if that's still too difficult you
can bend the knees
and now you're just going from here to
here and this should be a fairly gentle
exercise that most people can manage and
then of course the objective is to hold
that position for 30 seconds 60 seconds
longer or if you find that too easy to
find ways to make it more difficult
which we'll talk about in a moment what
this is then is it's a core
stabilization exercise in other words
you're training your core to become
better at stabilizing your body you're
resisting movement rather than creating
movement in this case it's anti-lateral
flexion meaning you're preventing your
body from flexing side to side this of
course is really useful if you're
carrying something heavy on one side and
you want to keep your body upright but
also has a lot of other benefits you see
this exercise and others like it are in
the frontal plane the frontal plane
being this which means moving from side
to side a lot of the exercises we do are
in the sagittal plane meaning forwards
and backwards up and down we don't do
enough in the transverse plane the
rotational plane either but I talk about
that plenty the frontal plane is just as
important whether you're an athlete
wanting to quickly change direction
whether you're just running and you want
to Dart around a tree or whether you're
just someone who wants to stabilize
themselves in that position as you're
walking and moving especially like I say
you're carrying something and this
becomes especially important as you get
older because the muscles you're going
to be strengthening here are some of the
ones that deteriorate fastest as we get
older probably because we're not really
using them very much stabilizing the
core is not just important to make sure
you can move healthily and continue to
move healthily it's not just important
for preventing injury it's also really
important for delivering power for
transferring power to the ground if your
core is floppy then when you push off
the ground what will happen is you'll
move your body instead of launching your
body your body will fold what you want
to happen is for your body to be
completely rigid so that when you launch
off you just go flying
frontal plane and of course if you want
to produce power in this way or prevent
someone from knocking you over in sports
then again you need training in this
plane and this exercise is particularly
good for that sometimes the muscles
we're working of course we're working
the obliques which run down the side of
the body these are overlooked muscles
are important for functional performance
but they're also important for
Aesthetics if you want to have a really
nice ripped looking six-pack then
creating more detail on either side is
one of the best hacks for doing that
you're also training the transverse
abdomini to an extent the kind of sheet
of muscle that wraps around your core
and helps you to brace this will help to
brace in all directions what's perhaps
the most important the most amazing is
what this can do for your spine which of
course is part of your core
foreign
ing pretty heavily now like why do I do
this to myself I have an office one of
the big ways that this stabilizes the
spine is by training the multifidus
muscles these are muscles that don't get
enough attention and should be talked
about a lot these are tiny muscles that
run down the side of the spine and Aid
with flexion either side stabilization
and rotation and we used to not think
much about them but now we know they're
actually the strongest fibers in the
human body so yeah we should probably
pay them some attention what's more is
that they're particularly rich in muscle
spindles and other proprioceptors
they're particularly Adept at sensing
movement and the way you actually use
them a lot of the time is by
anticipating movement if you're stepping
down a step on the way down the stairs
your body will brace the multifidus
muscles to support the spine prior to
your Landing so that you don't get that
unwanted jolt through the body this is
really important to train it's something
most of us ignore so if you want to
improve your spinal stability and your
core strength your athleticism and
prevent pain and injury then using a
variation of the side plank could be if
exactly what you need moreover if you
are someone who suffers with scoliosis
then this could be a tool that helps you
to address that you should definitely
speak with a doctor or a physiotherapist
or someone who can look at you and it's
not going to cure you overnight but this
is definitely a useful exercise that
will probably be prescribed to you if
you do struggle with that issue
as well as the spine the side plank is
also fantastic for stabilizing and
strengthening the hips and improving
your gait this is because it strengthens
the quadratus lumborum which you use to
keep your pelvis in line with your spine
this muscle connects the pelvis to the
lumbar spine and by strengthening it you
can this way prevent your hips from
dropping when you're running or walking
keeping them nicely in line this once
again helps to transfer more power to
the ground when you're sprinting and
walking
it's great for preventing injuries and
falls and of course it's also really
good for balance and of course the side
plank in general is really good for
balance especially if you perform it on
a narrow beam this is of course because
you're balancing your body listening to
all those proprioceptors specifically in
muscles that we very rarely use and as a
nice added bonus it's also great for
stabilizing the shoulder if you keep
your arm out straight and rest your body
on it then this is going to help you to
stabilize your scapula particularly
again in that position great if you want
to push someone over sideways or
generally support your weight in this
way oh my God
the rain is slightly holding off now for
you additionally what this also does is
it trains the glute Minimus and medius
these are again important for helping
you to stabilize your hips we often
think of our hip adductors and abductors
as bringing our legs together and moving
them apart respectively we think of this
as the primary function of those muscles
in fact though the primary function of
those muscles is to prevent movement to
keep our legs stable so that when we
walk they're in a straight line and our
knees are nicely stacked beneath our
hips obviously there are times where
having strength in those muscles can be
beneficial if you want to throw a side
kick for example or perform a middle
split or something like that but
generally what you really want to be
doing is training stabilization in these
muscles that's their primary function
and that's exactly what the side plank
trains
side plank tree
if you don't have a handy dandy tree to
use as a level then a great tip is to do
this in front of a mirror and that way
you can check that you really are
straight
finally the last thing that makes this
movement great is that it's unilateral
meaning you do it on just one side which
means you've got to turn around and do
it on the other side and this is great
for addressing imbalances if you're
someone for example who sits at a desk
or on a sofa and crosses your leg over
one side and you're always doing the
same leg this can actually lead to
shortness and tightness on one side in
the quadratus lumborum likewise if
you're someone who always carries a bag
on one side you might find that one set
of obliques are stronger than the other
I always carry my kids on one side so
I've got my other hand free for doing
things I try not to now but it's
something I've been doing for years and
it's hard to undo by doing this exercise
you can address those imbalances and
this is really important as we've talked
about keeping your hips stable as you're
moving helps you do not only prevent
Falls but also to exert Force equally
when you're running or sprinting all of
us have one leg that's slightly longer
than the other no one is completely
equal but if you can make your strength
as symmetrical as possible this is going
to transfer to better performance
imagine if one leg is producing just
slightly less Force than the other and
then you extrapolate that over the
course of an entire Marathon how much do
you think that could affect your time so
just by bringing up your slightly weaker
leg your slightly weaker hip to the same
level as the stronger one you could
drastically improve your performance
still think this is just an exercise for
toning
now I know what you might be thinking
this movement is still too easy for you
well have I got news for you now if
you're worrying that these movements are
too easy for you well then arrest
assured they're not there are plenty of
much harder variations that also will
challenge you in unique ways so for
example an easy way to make this
movement harder is to raise the leg
that's on Top This Will train your hip
abductors more as you're lifting the one
leg up in the air Against Gravity and
the other one now needs to work harder
because it doesn't have that extra
pillar of support on top of it keeping
you level on the ground training A
hip-hop ductus is a generally really
important it helps you to get in and out
of a deep squat so again don't think of
this as something that's you know only
for people who want to tone their glutes
it's actually really important if you
want a bigger and stronger squat as well
ease your free arm as well and you'll
make it an even more difficult balance
challenge if you want to add more
challenge to your core then you can take
a weight and hold it in position on top
you can even move the weight as well if
you want to train your rotator cuffs and
at the same time create even more of a
balance challenge because as the weights
moving forwards you're going to be
tempted to fall forwards as as well oh
and if you want to add rotation to this
movement then you can do a reach you can
try and reach through underneath
yourself and then reach up there's no
reaching for the ceiling or the sky this
works like a thread the needle it's
fantastic for also trading the
transverse plane so now you're training
rotation and frontal plane and one more
thing the great thing about movements
like this is that they're Dynamic
meaning that you're moving and therefore
stabilizing yourself as you move which
of course is what you actually would be
doing you don't just stand in one spot
normally if you want another Dynamic
version of this exercise and of course
you can go from being in a side plank
roll into a normal Plank and then roll
back out into another side plank you
could probably even go further back into
a reverse plank and this way you're just
rolling down the street like a weirdo
but it's great for building stability
throughout the core in a dynamic and fun
way
that's a whole bunch of more difficult
versions of this exercise but there's
one more that's particularly valuable
and that last really challenging
movement is the Copenhagen plank what
you're doing here is you're using a
bench to elevate the plank which of
course is another way you can generally
make it more difficult but at the same
time
you're only placing your upper leg on
top and now I'm using my hip adductors
to keep me up and you can even do little
bounces if you want to make it even more
challenging
build up to the little bounces this is a
very underutilized muscle for most of us
it's very easy to injure it
so if you found this video useful and
interesting guys let me know in the
comments down below do you use the side
plank and is it something you're going
to start using now what alternatives are
there that you enjoy using instead if
you did enjoy this video then please
consider leaving a like and sharing it
around that helps me out immensely and
the biggest thing you can do for me if
you would like to help out is to
subscribe to the channel I know that a
lot of people watch this channel
regularly who aren't subscribed and I'm
starting to get close to a million
subscribers it'll be a massive personal
Milestone if I could get to that point
so yeah if you are watching I'd
massively appreciate your subscribe if
you like this kind of training that
looks at all round functional
performance then check out my ebook and
training program super functional
training 2.0 that comes with over two
hours of video instruction and an 80
plus page ebook as well as a bunch of
bonus stuff this is a program designed
to not only build max strength not only
build Aesthetics but also to improve
Mobility cardio Mobility even brain
function all at the same time so you
don't have to choose just one thing to
focus on if that sounds interesting to
you then check it out I'll leave a link
in the description down below but either
way thank you so much to all of you for
watching this one I massively appreciate
it and I'll see you next time bye for
now
and did you know guys that this video
was sponsored by Squarespace Squarespace
is a website building platform that
makes it extremely easy for anyone to
build a website it drastically
streamlines the process using their
impressive fluid engine system until you
just drag and drop the elements you want
for your site on the screen it's
extremely intuitive and it takes minutes
instead of weeks and months you can then
customize it to your heart's content and
it has all the options you could
possibly need to extend the capabilities
of your website if you want to grow your
business you can add things like
e-commerce Advanced publishing tools
scheduling posts you've got a fully
integrated commenting system with
threaded comments replies and likes you
have member management analytics gated
members only areas for easy Revenue
generation and of course e-commerce for
selling a bunch of different items from
your website and if you need to extend
the capabilities of Squarespace even
further there are a bunch of different
plugins provided by the community for
example on the e-commerce site you can
add things like tax reconciliation
global Shipping and inventory management
the sky is the limit and it's extremely
easy to get started it removes that
barrier to entry so that anyone can have
a great website to promote their Hobbies
their interests or their business I
highly recommend Squarespace and if you
want to find out more you can go to
squarespace.com or when you're ready to
launch go to squarespace.com forward
slash bioneer to get 10 off your first
domain or website thank you so much
again to Squarespace for sponsoring this
video and thanks to you guys for
sticking around until the end and even
watching the sponsored segment you guys
are my favorites thanks guys
bye for now
[Music]